all right so I'm going to rephrase your
question and and just answer how do you
do a
yashi how do you do a step in this case
forward your feet are passing each other
okay uh as it is applied in
Kona so we know ultimately there's a
spiritual reconciliation of the two
minds
through a yashi we're going to take that
off the
T we also know energetically I have to
be able to manufacture I key an adhesion
at the contact point with
UK and then in order to do that I must
be able to let Yang energy enter my body
without displacing me which means there
must be some Integrity to where I am in
space okay
we're going to take that off the
table and we're going to look at the
physical component the physical
component is going to set me up for the
latter two components okay but we can
use uh what you might want to understand
as
biomechanics and we could maybe use that
to get in the doorway to understand
where and how my body has to be
organized for energetic reconciliation
okay uh and that's what we're going to
do now okay so we'll we'll measure our
integrity of our organization by our
ability to displace resistance
resistance is Young energy okay in this
case I'm not necessarily internalizing
it but it'll be able to tell whether my
body is organized to receive young
energy or not okay if I get displaced by
y energy or if I cannot displace yangong
energy there's no way I'll be able to
internalize Yang energy
okay so uh let you can put your joke
down let's get some basic concepts okay
first let's take kinesiological Concepts
regarding our basis support so we have
our center of gravity that's that
theoretical point in our body upon which
uh the rest of my form is balanced
balancing itself we have a line of
gravity that's a theoretical point from
that Center gravity point it's a
theoretical line from that center of
gravity Point perpendicular to the
surface so in that case the surface is
the mat my center of gravity is
somewhere in the middle of my body right
here and that line of gravity is
extended from that Center Point down to
the mat that's my line of
gravity and then the other the third one
we want is the Bas of support the pace
of support is my contact points with the
surface in this case the mat and the
area shaded in between them whenever my
line of gravity is within my basis
support I will have equilibrium whenever
my line of Gravity Falls outside my Bas
of support such as when I lean forward
my Center gravity is going up my body
but that line of gravity is moving out
because it remains perpendicular from
the center of gravity and eventually it
falls out outside my basis support and I
will eventually lose my balance okay so
those are the three things we want to
understand initially Center gravity line
of gravity and Bas of
support uh when it comes to displacing
Yang energy and this case resistance and
not being displaced by it I have to
understand where I have energy leakage
in my
yashi and I will always have energy leak
leage whenever my line of Gravity Falls
outside my Bas of support okay um but
there's a
catch I'll also have energy
leakage when that when I don't get a
single when I don't unify my contact
point with the Earth and my basis
support when I have my line of gravity
between my feet such that it's between
my cont points but it is within my Bas
of support you're going to lose power
okay so we're going to have you run a
couple experiments on that okay uh so a
yashi here is a resistance he can push
on it okay and I want you to put your
line of gravity in the middle of your
two contact points in the middle of your
two feet leaving the line of gravity in
the middle of your two feet I want you
you to try to displace him walking
forward you can give a little energy
okay what you're going to see is as soon
as you take that foot off the
ground you this foot is useless and you
will not be able to go forward on him he
will push you off
okay so that's your first little
experiment run it put your line of
gravity between your feet and try to
move keeping it there you and he has
great enough resistance it's going to
displace me okay the other one I want
you to do is he'll let me get that step
I don't care where you put your line of
gravity now but you're going to get that
step he's going to resist really hard
right there and I'm going to Rudder that
foot Rudder is when my back foot moves
up the circle okay I'll do it again
you'll let me get that step you'll give
great resistance here and you're you're
going to see that I'm bouncing off of
him because energy is coming out of that
ruding foot why because my line of
gravity is back in between those two
feet as I rotated okay so again our two
experiments here great resistance try to
go forward great you I got it give me
greater
man okay and then the next one he'll let
me take that step then hard when I get
through step hard and R and you'll see
you're bouncing off the H okay let's
just experience these two energy
leakages okay go so I'm I'm going to
demonstrate it because he didn't quite
give give me the the resistance that I
wanted so he he's going to try to walk
forward go he's he's never going to do
it try it again he's never going to do
it that's actually where you do stop
hits you know so where you take you get
kazushi with stop hits It's the guy's in
mid stride but he has to be walking that
way okay so for example He he'll take
that step towards me just a step like
step we're working on a yashi okay so he
takes the step and in the step I pop him
he's going to go off balance or as he's
walking towards me boom I kick on that
step you can see his line of gravity is
between so your always look for that uh
and you're doing your like he's over
here and he's lipping off or whatever
and then I see him when you pop him in
the throat you get way more displacement
than the little strike actually
generates but it's because of the way
the line of gravity was in the middle of
his two contact points okay and he's
trying to go
forward um on the second one I'll give
him the first and yumii but you have to
rud her the back foot okay there's the
first one and you see the Joe goes that
way at the end okay again it's not
merely a matter of the back foot of the
line of gravity being between the two
contact points it is but he's also
losing degree of penetration so if you
make a fist you see and as he moves that
back foot up the circle you'll see that
he's actually losing penetration and we
use that all the time when we want to go
to the zon of sanctuary and get out of
the way of his weapon so if my weapon is
hitting him here if he now moves that
way he's got range between us you see
okay so uh we don't want to Rudder
that's what I call it when your foot
moves around we never want to Rudder is
very common in iido but is very
incorrect um and we we don't want to
have our line of gravity between our two
contact points I for tonight are going
to call that double waiting we don't
want to double weight okay what we want
to do
instead is shift our line of gravity
from one contact
point to the other contact Point okay so
uh at the midfoot so I'm going to shift
my weight so that I'm on the midfoot and
I'm going to give you I'm on the Yang
aspect of the midfoot the Yang aspect of
the midfoot so my front knee is going to
go all the way to my
toes okay so my my ankle is forward you
see but I'm not going to go past my toes
that's going to jack you up but my ankle
is not
straight I'm going to bring my knee to
my toe line this line
here this is too far you're going to
injure yourself and you will your line
of gravity is now forward of the midfoot
which is incorrect and inapplicable at
the energetic phase so I'm midfoot but
young midfoot
okay come this way he's giv me that same
resistance I'm going to
go young midfoot think of it knee to
toes and then all my weight is on this
foot so this there's no weight on this
foot which means my line of gravity is
not between my contact points it'll get
stuck midfoot y here there's no weight
but I can move forward using the mid
foot of the previous foot and I do the
same thing here knee to tow line and
then drive with that ground Vector
forward I don't care how you step your
foot right now I'm exaggerating by
lifting the foot boom I have that
positive angle drive that midfoot Vector
in Step boom
step so he's pushing he's pushing push
push okay and I'm
moving okay let's try it
go okay so
you actually do this in your Kona if you
pay attention you're going to do what is
called half Moone so as I shift here
you're going to you're going to see that
as I bring all my weight to that single
Pivot Point my feet aren't going to stay
apart if I my feet stay apart my line of
gravity is not on this point so my feet
come
together push and then they'll go out so
you are Happ half mooning feet together
half mooning
okay so if I do
uh EO for example I
help you're going to see that this leg
does not go there this leg is going to
pass by the other
foot you're half moving in into
your
okay
key though is that your line of gravity
is entirely on one contact point where
the midfoot of whatever ground you're
whatever foot you're using for the
ground
vectoring again we took the energetic
off the table because energetically it's
not necessary but to get you in the ball
part this is how to do it
okay all right let us
work not with a punch but with the Palm
heel so we don't break anything okay um
and I'm going to
do those
same
Dynamics but not
ring okay so I'm going to do a
yashi push and I would like for you to
try one
ruding
push and then
ruding okay let's try it go people that
Rudder always feel powerful in ruding
it's hard for them to realize that
you're losing power so uh we'll increase
the level of resistance so that you
could see it okay uh so come uh stand be
near his
back we just increase the mass
see okay and I'm not using my arm
strength my arm is more like a like the
Joe it's just a Jou Ste is telling me my
ashaki is correct okay
so or
R okay try it go okay uh so one of the
de here pointed out this is a good point
so we'll make it for you okay so when
when you
Runner your line of gravity is between
your
feet which means it's not going to be on
the midfoot
vector we we did take the energetic
aspect off the table but we are doing it
consistently across both elements so uh
the force or the let's say the
anatomical structure that can displace
mass is also the same anatomical
structure that can internalize the Yang
energy okay so uh when I hit his Mass
there's an equal and opposite energy so
when I hit his Mass there's a y energy
that comes back
okay it happens very quickly but that y
energy gets internalized it hits
whatever midfoot I needed to hit in this
case it would be the back foot and it's
going to generate the tanden field I'm
going to be able to rotate the tonden
field and if necessary koku project him
off okay so it's not that I'm I'm in in
throwing matter at
him that's not what's what's happening
in in iido okay what's happening is that
as as you touch the resistance it
generates the Yang uh energy I
internalize the Yang energy it's going
to bounce off of the ground boom and
that's what's hitting him when we do our
Coq projections from uh any kind of grab
technique it's just a less Dynamic
version of when when I
hit okay uh but it's the same exact
mechanics okay so for example I'm never
I'm never hitting this the surface of
him his Mass goes through generates that
entire thing and you have a
ballistic more Dynamic CQ projection
okay that's what we're trying to do so
in order to do that the back foot has to
be engaged in this case because that's
the foot that's going to be the
grounding foot okay um so why don't we
try just a little percussiveness I don't
want you to hurt anyone okay but we'll
do it with multiple
people and it's really because it's it's
it's my boys here I want you to feel
what's going to happen Okay so in the
last one when I pushed you right
remember and I just pushed you you felt
the the energy be displaced you all you
went backwards you see that right now
this resistance is going to increase
what the Yang energy so the Y now when I
go
ballistic it's going to go into his
body
um and and more stay in his body okay as
opposed to this is pushing you you
see this one you'll feel it more in your
body so don't do it too hard okay so
just in his
body see same displacement
back on
him okay and you can hear the th of it
with just a little flick of the wrist
okay all right let's see what you
get okay so another way uh you don't
have to hit your partner and do it okay
is uh you'll just do the the standard C
you okay so we're focusing on the back
foot cannot run it you need it for your
midfoot so what what I'm going to do is
is uh push get them to be that young
energy you see like I I don't want him
to have that space I want to I want to
Stack Up You See It generates more young
energy okay so that goes into the back
foot and you'll be able to project them
and it's the same mechanically is the
exact same thing uh as a ballistic
strike okay so one more time ground and
mid vector midfoot vector the back foot
get the Yang energy going and then boom
project out okay let's try it okay we'll
take that now into the yumii Drone okay
so I move
move and then we do the other
side shift
move okay let's try yeah okay so if
you're doing a yashi in EO you're going
to look for these things so the knee is
going to go to the toes I'm going to
bring a line of gravity to one contact
point at a time I'll probably half moon
in the technique especially because of
the spiring geometry of iido Kaza
architectures okay um but it's
definitely
not that you
see no okay so if I was doing it with
strikes you would see uh bring the knee
to the toe line of gravity comes to that
foot push off of that one foot leave it
in place boom and then you would strike
okay in EO we'll do IH me first it's
right here there's the shift there's the
single line push back fo stays where it
is and then again as I move
forward it doesn't matter if I'm doing
po that is the same thing here it is
right there in push
[Music]
push this
knee
it's not going to work
okay thank
you so you see how you picked that foot
up that's cuz your line of gravity is
between your two contact
points better but you kind of fell
right pick up the pace more energy push
push
push more
energy you picked your foot up
again there's that foot up and you see
energy is leaking behind you
okay energy
Ronin you guys see you get what I'm
talking energy is
leaking so as uh
just you're pushing on me you're pushing
him you see and they're pushing
me I'm not going to get there and just
like the Jo drill you see so I have to
be on this foot and that foot has to
shift so it's not on this foot this foot
now moves and then I shift to this foot
and then this foot now goes
in
okay oh here and I can
move okay
so one more
indicator you pick your foot up high
it's almost guaranteed that your line of
gravity is between the two feet okay if
you watch watch my feet they're sliding
on the
M why because line of gravity is on one
foot that's why the other foot can move
freely okay so we going and you'll see
how my feet are
sliding okay so let's try to get the
sliding feet too go